by being a racing driver you are on the
risk all the time i used those lines and
those guidelines to move as a man as a
professional I like to to do well I like
to be the best I am as committed as ever
to my passion everyone is responsible
for the race having being stuck I'm only
32 and his no sense for me to start my
understanding was that he would never
move against me in the first corner
is a Brazilian race driver who won three
Formula One World Championships he was
killing them accident while leading the
1994 70 grand prix he's considered by
many as the greatest race car driver of
all time he's our ten Santa's and here
are his top 10 persistence you should
know that by being a racing driver you
are on the risk all the time by being a
racing driver means you are racing with
other people and if you no longer go for
a gap that exists you no longer a racing
driver because we are competing we are
competing to win and and the main
motivation to all of us is to compete
for a victory is not to come third
fourth fifth or sixth okay compiler to
do for Milan prestige meetings tia
cabeza trois a cambiado chicken s si he
pleases pornsta to do sepsis Oh team
winta when cacama tranquilla dodgy y-yes
s odia us abscissa diste gentei keijo
menta mijita guarda sedanos chicas chin
seen on Dewey procurando minimizes
Mikado's na e e con calma ashke hey
group responds a b c Sakura youngren
problem solving t lipstick ontology
fuzzy to go home they also meet us in
putting sensors a certain age mice they
hunt if you play near the top Lanier in
the kids thinking VIN cuando free other
I have had all my life very very strong
in good education and from that
education have got again clear and
strong principles in way of behaving and
that's where I'm guide for I come I used
those lines and those guidelines to move
as a man as a professional and and I
don't regret anything I just feel I'm
doing things for the right reason some
others
some don't in the end you never get
everybody to understand to agree and to
accept but most of them I'm sure admire
after all what I am doing as as a
professional and as a man and as many
drivers do we are exposing our lives
they are consistent and the reason for
it is only one is to succeed is to win
is to get the 30 when you cross the
finish line in first place I am very
competitive I think any racing driver
that gets to Formula One has in its
personality a lot of competitiveness I
particularly believed to be extremely
competitive in anything I do but it
depends where you are and what you're
doing what is your state of mind if I am
on holiday offseason
it's a different way of living totally
then when you do interviews when you're
testing during the season racing
completing you in the season you have to
allow yourself different mental approach
a different way of looking the day and
night and and only that way I find
possible to get the necessary librium to
then give everything I have when it
really matters but in normal things I'm
competitive I like to complete and I
like to to do well I like to be the best
ome responsabilidades Toby's my are
dokie todos mis penas con mini nada nah
wanna costly as porky agencia me
cessna's classes uma menina so you n
cali me grande y su mo chiva mais linda
voz a rock yatras mucho como queda
special prayers y intercede Oh sobre
todo mi esposa build our co infancia
Kwasniewski ghazni cojida levanto said
oh y pegar una casa de pie and I said am
i carrying Clavio Todd warm up East
anything yep rakia toh hamesha Beth
rocky new conan contra missing addend it
has been quite incredible season for you
you are the youngest ever three times
world champion three times in four years
I have to ask you on behalf of your
despairing rivals is your motivation
still as high as ever I think so
I I am as I said young and healthy I am
as committed as ever to my passion to
our passion and to my profession and the
main thing is to find ways time after
time to stimulate myself in my own world
dying my own funny ways to dedicate a
lot of my time a lot of my thinking and
keep up with the commitment that is
quite high to continue to be successful
if we were to run into rain conditions
of this kind again is there a better
method ayrton for us to look into how
the race should be stopped earlier or
more positively we shouldn't start but
whose decision is that it I think it's
very hard for the officials to make such
a decision because there is a lot of
pressure television all over the world
and it's difficult we understand but I
think it's in a way is our own fault we
should have started the drivers if we
just get out of the cars stick together
and make a decision for ourselves then
the race wouldn't start in first place
it's always very difficult to get
everyone together I experienced it
myself two years ago today again because
also we have a lot of responsibility to
the teams and the sponsors that give us
so much and there are moments that we
have to also try to give them something
but he's very difficult to find the
equilibrium the balance on making the
right decisions at every single time but
as I said I think it was a mistake to
all of us to have start not only from
the officials it was also a drivers
mistake was a cheese mistake we all
should have had courage as a group
everyone that is here to get together
and go against it and not reached and
not start the race so it's not a fish
was only I also take responsibility
thick as drivers and also the team
everyone is responsible for the race
having been stunned i express the
feeling some time ago a couple of months
ago that time I wouldn't be prepared to
continue driving next year unless I
thought I could compete competitive and
that meant not that I had to leave
McLaren or anything it just meant if you
feel you you have some light at the end
of the tunnel in which you can work and
make up and be back there on in a
competitive way and if that situation
did not turn up for me then I wouldn't
drive without really wishing to stop
because I mean I am only 32 and it's no
sense for me to stop I mean the peak of
my career is to you with quite a few
years ahead I have achieved so much
credibility in so much experience that
is is not the time to stop but on the
other hand absolutely nonsense to just
be a number out there giving the fact
that whether you fight him for first or
second or a fee for a six you just
exposing yourself to a lot of danger
continuously a lot of stress
and a lifestyle that not always is he's
attractive for me therefore considering
everything the material benefits i got
up until now and the ones i could get in
the future the personal satisfaction and
achievements that you can get the only
real motivation for me to continue was
to to be in a position where i could
compete improve learn more and and be
there you know be there fighting at
least for it and anything else just i
could not justify to myself he moved to
the inside line going towards the first
corner i just chase him then and he
opened the gap and knowing me like he
does know he must realize that if there
was a gap i was the Detroit overtaking
and an underdose Acosta's he should
never have opened a gap in the first
corner and then come back again because
by doing so he opened the gap gave the
gap and then close it and in that
sequence that there was no way to avoid
an incident right but that only happened
in because you saw the gap and I accept
that your eraser but amateur racer has
to also think if he closes the door
again we are going to have an accident
and in fact that was a high-speed entry
so it could have been a very serious
accident so wouldn't it not have been
more prudent under those circumstances
to have at least seen that the gap was
potentially going to close not at all he
was in a position where he could never
under no circumstance put his car
anywhere near mine in a difficult
position because if we happen just to
touch just to touch and have a wing
damaged or a wheel flat tire he had
everything to lose so and under those
circumstances my understanding was that
he would never move against me in the
first
and I was very surprised when I found
myself with him moving the car over mine
so in that case you were calculating
that he would give way that he would let
you through of course he would not close
the way he did from the moment he made
the initial room he would not come back
and close the door again a calculated
risk of course wait- a sido una gran
from the brazil he basically from a sort
no hana family same PG seek our brains
join the hey guys
Oh
No
I pulled out believe it was then really
faced with a very easy race win
the gearbox jammed and he was faced with
several laps to go only having the
six-year Paris in repeal otero
Cardiff amo mucho trabajo NOS esta mas
le kiryat a para el MPG ah mais question
you are mice Aditya tempah delta z ratio
grant Ramirez you here in control dentro
de Lima for special
Oh
ah
did it go you all yeah you is my hope
for you will show more mental maze le
vivid obese de garça stream we achieve a
sparse crowd oohs aahs in the Pisco see
ya de la arab slogan of Nazi money
Jericho stress off a morbid lots of
pieces they were Kabakov either say
another syringe thank you so much for
watching we made this video because the
veg somani asked us to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want us to
propound next leave in the comments
below and we'll see what we can do we
would love to know which one of his top
10 rules that you like the most please
leave the comment below we will join in
a discussion thank you guys for watching
to believe and we'll see you soon